there's a lot of excitement with chat
GPT the large language model
so some people are saying that perhaps
it can replace teachers uh let's I
wanted to test it out so I'm teaching
Advanced mechanics of solids but I gives
it something easier to do first of all I
asked it to write an introductory
lecture on the topic of torsion for the
class and mechanics of solids as you can
see here so it started out very nicely
here this is actually very good ah
there's nothing wrong here very general
uh interesting kind of thing this is
like this is me testing it out for the
first time here
I use it I don't have any stored
conversations yet so
uh
this is good and then I asked you to
follow it up with the derivation for the
formula of the shear stress for the
torsion of a shaft
so what it gave here is a little bit
worrisome because it is giving up in the
formulas tau is equal to T by J
that is not correct
okay so anyone who has studied torsion
will know that tau is equal to T R by J
so this uh this equation is not even
dimensionally correct so it has given
some explanations which is good but the
formula itself is wrong so I told it
that there's a mistake in the formula of
the shear stress in the previous
response please correct it and answer
again so very nicely it has apologized
for the mistake and then it gave
something which is even worse so this
doesn't make any sense this particular
formula it doesn't make any sense but
then it again wrote it very nicely
um
but then I again told it it is still
wrong it should be this tau is equal to
tr by J
and I even gave it uh the the correct
expression for the G I think for the J
it was giving it correctly earlier
anyway so it again says I apologize
again for the mistake very very polite
uh us and it says that you are correct
so I am correct all right and it is uh
it is it is accepted my suggestion and
it has given this thing okay great so as
far as Distortion is concerned by itself
it would it was not able to give the
correct thing
uh let's see if we can go for some other
kind of a discussion
maybe something from flexure
uh
let's give something similar give an
introductory lecture
on
bending stresses
for a class on mechanics of solids
this is very common topic
um
let's see if it can do this
foreign
bending stress is a type of mechanical
stress that occurs when a force is
applied to an object and it causes the
object to bend okay good this type of
stress occurs in objects such as beams
bars and rocks that are subjected to a
load that carries a bending moment fine
the bending stress is proportional to
the load applied and the distance from
the neutral axis okay it's getting
technical now which is Axis in the cross
section of the object that remains
unstressed under bending so this part I
really like so I think in many textbooks
it is it is written wrongly regarding
the neutral axis but it has defined this
thing correctly here good so bending
stress is different from axial stress
which occurs when a force is applied
along the longitudinal axis of an object
causing it to stretch or compress all
right the formula for bending stress is
calculate calculated on the pending
moment divided by the second moment of
area this also I like very much the
second movement of area business uh some
some textbooks is written as moment of
inertia I personally prefer it as second
moment of area
so that's good let's see the actual
formula
oh man
foreign
student even can tell you that this is
not M by I this is m y by I this is
dimensionally incorrect
it is written so many subsequent things
but the formula itself is incorrect I
have to tell it to correct
uh
nice explanation but the formula itself
is incorrect
please correct it
let's see if it can correct itself
it is very polite I have to give it this
much
very very polite
ah now it gives it correctly
good my by I
thank you for pointing out the mistake
I I wish I wish students of this
generation were as polite as
uh
as this large language model anyway so
good
can you perhaps give
some real world
examples
where the bending stress formula is
applied
so this is a question I often face from
my students let's see if it can give
nice examples nice application examples
here
bridges are subjected to loads from
Vehicles when earthquakes Engineers use
the bending stress formula to determine
the bending stress in the beams and
girus that make up the bridge is
structured this information is then used
to design the bridge
so there are certain things in which
this is actually very good where we have
to use words and describe things in a
very qualitative fashion it is really
good uh
nice
it is typing things out faster than I
can speak
aircraft wings
good
this is actually very very good examples
bicycle frames this is my favorite
example
all right so Engineers use the bending
stress form to determine the maximum
bending stress in the frame I mean
it doesn't have a brain of its own so
when it is pulling from various sources
it it is kind of a big being a little
bit repetitive I would not say things
like this in a class uh maybe try to
make it a little bit more interesting
but as far as the correctness of the
examples are concerned this is
absolutely fine
these are just a few examples how the
bending stress formula is used in real
about the applications by understanding
and applying the formula Engineers can
design objects that are strong and safe
for the loads that will be subjected to
all right
can you give
some examples
where
the
pending stress formula
may not be used
so if a student asks this question I
understand where what the student is
asking me let's see if it can understand
this thing this is a little bit tricky
okay so I laid a trap for it and it fell
into it so uh so when a student
basically asks when a bending stress
formula cannot be used he he or she is
asking actually about the limitations of
it uh
regarding uh like in what kind of
geometry you may not use it so even if
there is bending moment uh we cannot use
that kind of a formula
depending on certain parametric regimes
of the aspect ratios of the beam
but here it has understood it completely
differently
what it has answered it is technically
not wrong
but in a classroom situation as a
teacher I would understand what the
student would mean but it has completely
failed it has given examples from other
chapters of mechanics of service so of
course we cannot use a bending stress
formula I mean you can give other
examples like buckling and other things
where the bending stress formula cannot
be used
so okay ah
can you perhaps
give some
examples
or maybe I I give it a bit more hint
um
even if a beam is subjected
to
a bending moment
under what
restrictions
ah
the bending stress formula cannot be
used I think I've gone
the wording may be a little bit
confusing but let's see if it can
if it can address this
all right under certain assumptions and
conditions what are those
uh
used to include non-uniform cross
sections
um okay
remains constant and uniform along its
length okay that's good that's actually
very good non-linear material Behavior
very very good
good large deformations
right
well now it is just going away on a
tangent of course for temperature
changes we cannot use this but this is
the third point is very good the large
deformations thing
uh now this is just going away
completely on a tangent
but I think I think overall overall this
is good uh
especially I like like its answers
regarding the non-linear material
Behavior and the and the large
deformations
um
in the previous response
okay in the previous response can you
include a point regarding
the influence of the aspect ratio of the
beam cross section
on the
pending stress formula
restrictions
I'll be really impressed if it can give
it
if we can give the correct answer to
this
okay
I don't know whether it is thinking or
it's getting too much loaded
did I break it
perhaps I should have made it clearer
it's not giving anything
come on
I wonder what happens if I write
something in between
it's giving something
okay
it's still sticking with the norm cross
section
I'll just stop generating this thing
uh maybe I'll just let it let it do its
thing
I'll make the I'll make the suggestion
clear
okay it's hiding something
ah it is trying to give something
I don't know what happened here anyway
uh what he was trying to say it is it is
I think it was going in the right
direction I wonder what happens
uh
okay
okay I'll give it to it it's
is done a much better job than I would
have expected
it's really impressive
okay I'll save and submit anyway
I think this is good enough
uh what if I write this
foreign
cross section Dimensions is not too
large compared to the
um
uh sorry the ratio of the beam cross
section Dimensions to the length of the
beam
is not
too small
let's see if it can get this
okay it is taking to that answer
uh so to a student who is so this is
actually problematic so it is going into
the kind of things
uh which I would not discuss while
discussing bending of beams uh because I
know what the student
knows and does not know and uh since
since the whole topic of this discussion
was whether it chat GPT can replace a
teacher uh I think at its current level
of sophistication uh I mean
I mean it is very capable certainly it's
very capable as we have seen But there
are certain things which a teacher can
understand uh what can be discussed and
may not be discussed in front of a
student who has some prior knowledge or
not
uh this as it as it currently stands is
not able to do it and of course it
cannot do it okay maybe I'm expecting
way too much of it uh but I am impressed
by by first of all by the fluency of it
it is wonderful I mean
um it is indeed a language model and
even the technical correctness of it
with a little bit of a prompting from my
from me it is quite good
okay and and I think as if I keep on
using it it'll it'll learn from me and
then
um
it'll get better okay so there you have
it this was my little reaction to how uh
there is me or how there may be a
possibility of chat GPT replacing me
I think for now I'm okay
thank you